so are your kids aren't in like Catholic
School in cathol they in Catholic school
they're in Catholic school cuz I felt
like I have girls so it's like if you
know there's never been a priest priest
never diddled a chick yeah and we every
girl I know who went to Catholic School
wasn't sucking dick by 14 that's for
sure my daughter's a Catholic school you
know their mom is like a wild Latino
girl with a tattoo in hert and their
father's just a comedian who talks about
getting fisted in the ass by his
uncle they're toast your kids no shot
you're like yeah Kath will be fine
they're not no girls get molested over
there no you're right priest are mostly
gay I do though feel like with Catholic
school you know like when they say like
if you survive a plane crash like you're
good like it will never happen again how
many more kids can they honestly click
the whole world is watching them you
can't get away with it now so I think
now is the safest time on September 12th
take a vacation to Manhattan it's not
happening again I only fly on
911 will not Happ that's smart man
you're a [__] genius for that one do